[Música]
culpable de cinco cargos fue encontrada
Kiley Maxwell pareja del fallecido
multimillonario Jeffrey Epstein
señalados de liderar una red de abuso
sistemático de menores desde mediados de
la década de los 90
los presidentes de Estados Unidos y
Rusia hablarán este jueves
telefónicamente sobre las tensiones en
Ucrania está preocupado por la presencia
de tropas rusas en la zona limítrofe y
Vladimir Putin exige garantías de
seguridad de accidentes
ya hace 2 años China alertó a la
Organización Mundial de la Salud sobre
una neumonía viral que luego sería
reconocida como covid-19 hoy el director
del organismo dice que las variantes del
está y Omicron crean un tsunami de
positivos
este es un nuevo resumen informativo en
francés 24 lo saluda Daniel hablando
comenzamos hablando de la británica
Guilin Maxwell quién fue hallada
culpable de delitos de tráfico sexual
por un jurado de Nueva York la antigua
pareja del multimillonario fallecido
Jeffrey Epstein estaba acusada de
colaborar en el reclutamiento de menores
para que fueran abusadas sexualmente por
este magnate más en el siguiente informe
James Maxwell es culpable de cinco de
los seis cargos de los que se la acusaba
incluyendo el de tráfico de menores es
el veredicto después de 5 días completos
de deliberación del jurado en uno de los
casos de más alto perfil desde la
irrupción del movimiento me too contra
el abuso sexual el juicio en su contra
comenzó en Nueva York el 29 de noviembre
un día que las víctimas del
multimillonario fallecido Jeffrey
Epstein catalogaron como esperanzador
y particular las sobrevivientes de
Jeffrey Epstein y como yo fueron
privadas de un día en la corte pero
tengo fe en el sistema de justicia y sé
que el jurado llegará a una conclusión
correcta
es la primera vez que he hablado con
ella personalmente en 500 días desde que
comenzó su prisión preventiva
se la acusaba de 6 cargos vinculados con
un supuesto esquema de tráfico sexual
que lideraba Jeffrey Epstein entre ellos
conspiración de menores y tentar a una
menor a viajar para participar en actos
sexuales ilegales los fiscales
recordaron sus vínculos con Sting con
quién mantuvo una relación sentimental y
dirigió varios de sus negocios el
magnate se suicidó en una cárcel en
Manhattan en 2019 tenía 66 años y
esperaba un juicio por abuso sexual
y en otras noticias este jueves los
presidentes de Estados Unidos Joe Biden
y de Rusia Vladimir Putin sostendrán una
llamada telefónica para discutir entre
otros temas la creciente tensión en
Ucrania en Washington se dice que va a
ir en la insistirá has homólogo ruso que
está preparado para responder ante una
eventual invasión a territorio vecino la
administración Valentín continúa
participando en una extensa diplomacia
con nuestros aliados y socios europeos
consultando y coordinando un enfoque
común en respuesta a la concentración
militar de Rusia en la frontera con
Ucrania el presidente ballena hablado
con líderes de toda Europa y los
funcionarios de la Administración Bailén
se han comprometido multilateralmente
con la OTAN y la Unión Europea y la hoxe
en funcionarios también han tenido
numerosas consultas con sus homólogos
incluidos los de los países del flanco
oriental de forma bilateral y en el B 9
así como con Ucrania
información de la pandemia en América
Latina bolivia no ha detectado ningún
caso de contagio con la variante Omicron
pero si lucha por contener el creciente
número de casos algunas ciudades
suspendieron fiestas de fin de año
previamente autorizadas y el Gobierno
Nacional anuncio otras medidas
previamente hablamos con Mary vaca
nuestra corresponsal en La Paz para
conocer cómo está la situación en el
país
hola qué tal buenas noches ustedes que
en Bolivia se ha producido un
relajamiento de las normas de
bioseguridad que ha coincidido con las
fiestas de fin de año y las reuniones
por la Navidad por eso es que se ha dado
esta explosión de casos que ha obligado
a las autoridades a tomar en nuevas
medidas sucede que alrededor del 60% de
la población vacunables decir la mayor
de 18 años accedido al esquema completo
de vacunación y con esa confianza mucha
gente ha empezado a retomar su vida con
normalidad pero ha seguido contagiando o
contagiándose de covid-19 y
lamentablemente lo que más están
sufriendo las consecuencias en este
punto de la pandemia son los no
vacunados porque los reportes indican
que las unidades de terapia intensiva
están llenas básicamente con gente que
no se ha vacunado ya sea por sus
creencias o por desinformacion y nuestra
corresponsal en la pasta menos hablo de
las medidas están tomando los gobiernos
locales
los alcaldes de las principales ciudades
de Bolivia en tomado la decisión de
prohibir las fiestas de año nuevo que en
un principio si las habían autorizado
además en dos grandes ciudades como son
Santa Cruz y el alto se ha decidido ir a
una ley seca lo que significa que los
próximos 10 días estará prohibido el
consumo de bebidas alcohólicas por otro
lado el Gobierno central ha tomado la
decisión de exigir a todos los
ciudadanos bolivianos que quieran
ingresar a un lugar donde hay
aglomeración de gente el carnet de
vacunación lo que ha generado protestas
de parte de los grupos antivacunas que
exigen la derogatoria de este Decreto
hace 2 años en la víspera de Año Nuevo
China alertó a la Organización Mundial
de la Salud sobre una veintena de casos
de una extraña neumonía que luego sería
el 19 hoy el director del organismo
asegura que la circulación simultánea de
las variantes del está io micrón está
creando un tsunami de casos
[Música]
mientras la mayor parte del planeta se
celebraba el fin del 2019 una nueva
amenaza energía el 31 de diciembre de
2019 China alertó a la Organización
Mundial de la Salud de 27 casos de una
neumonía viral de origen desconocido
identificados en la ciudad de Wuhan lo
que semanas más tarde sería catalogado
como el charco 2 virus que produce el
covid-19 oficialmente el primer caso de
la gripe de Wuhan fuera de China se
registró en Tailandia el 13 enero 2020 y
rápidamente se extendió por todo el
mundo
es desarrollo y distribución de una
vacuna dividió la opinión pública siendo
la OMS principal promotor de la
inoculación pese a que más de 9000000 de
2 y se han administrado mundialmente en
un año las autoridades sanitarias se
lamenta no haber alcanzado las metas
propuestas
online
maticas y graves son los que no se han
vacunado una vez que las mascarillas y
el testeo ya son un denominador en las
culturas de todo el mundo la OMS confía
en que el 2022 ponga fin a la fase aguda
de la pandemia
a continuación más noticias del
coronavirus para esta vez en Europa en
Francia 2 ciudadanos son diagnosticados
con covid-19 cada segundo según el
Ministerio de Salud el país contabilizo
en la última jornada 208000 nuevos casos
que marcaron no solamente un nuevo
récord nacional signo europeo
España por su parte redujo el periodo de
aislamiento de 10 a 7 días para quienes
resulten positivos por covit19 pero sean
asintomáticos o presenten un cuadro leve
de la enfermedad a medida que la falta
de personal debido a los largos
aislamientos causa interrupciones en
algunas industrias el país ibérico
supero este miércoles la barrera de los
100000 contagios
y en Grecia desde este jueves entrarán
en vigor nuevas restricciones tras
registrar un recordatorio de contagios
los bares discotecas y restaurantes
tendrán que cerrar a la medianoche y no
podrán atender a clientes de pies ni
tener música solo en la víspera de Año
Nuevo podrán permanecer abiertos hasta
las 2 de la mañana
y finalizamos con imágenes imágenes de
un festín en un zoológico de Berlín en
Alemania como todos nosotros los
habitantes de este lugar también están
celebrando las fiestas de fin de año
pero de manera muy particular comiendo
sus árboles de Navidad esos
tradicionales pinos nunca fueron
vendidos y utilizados pero si sirvieron
de golosinas para elefantes renos y
demás inquilinos de este zoológico con
estas imágenes nos despedimos a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía
[Música]